now it may then come as a surprise  to the most naive among us anyway  that the very same media which complains  bitterly about whites in traditionally  non-white roles and the very same  leftists who treat the whitening of  non-white characters as literal genocide  and all the people who've taken this  issue so seriously as to cause many  white hollywood actors to drop out of  films and fall to their knees and  apology  would all this week be so excited about  the release of the first trailer for  disney's upcoming little mermaid live  action copy and paste job now everything  is mostly the same in the remake as  always it's like shot for shot exactly  except  that the little mermaid herself a pale  redhead in the cartoon version has been  recast as a black woman though still  with red hair somehow  this is part of a growing trend as the  anger about whitewashing increases  so in equal proportion does the demand  for what we must in the reverse call  blackwashing